gas prices are now at a level we have
never seen before overnight aaa reported
the nationwide average for a gallon of
regular reached five dollars that's up
nearly two dollars from one year ago the
fastest inflation rate in more than 40
years doesn't seem to be slowing down
anytime soon according to the labor
department consumer prices surged 8.6
percent in may that's the highest figure
since 1981.
the economic worries are fueling a slump
on wall street on friday the dow and s p
500 index each lost more than two and a
half percent while the nasdaq fell more
than three percent here to help us make
sense of some of this
is our cbs business news business
analyst jill schlesinger jill
8.6
increase in may and the greatest in what
41 years what happened um well this was
a worse than expected report we did
think inflation was going to tick down a
little bit
primarily the big categories are just
going up so much faster than anybody
thought so you mentioned gas all of
energy the whole complex up by more than
30 percent food up more by by more than
10 percent but even things like shelter
so renting and owning homes it's more
expensive some of the sub categories are
really intense i just want to give you
some of these food at grocery stores up
11.9 it's the highest increase since
1978.
we also know that the
war in ukraine really pushing up prices
for a lot of wheat products so cookies
and pasta so you know what the problem
is that you'd say oh i'll eat cheaper
tonight rice and beans and you know what
everything is more expensive everything
is yeah i can't find anything that is
less expensive the dow
is now down nine of the past 10 weeks
um it it tested a bottom we thought a
few weeks ago and then came back up and
now it's gone back down again i'm not
going to ask you
if you think
investors should buy or sell because
you're just going to say don't panic
which is the correct advice but how long
do you think this volatility lasts for i
think this volatility will continue for
a long time because remember we're
coming off of three unbelievable years
for stock investors and bond investors
this year things really did change why
because high inflation but also because
the federal reserve is raising interest
rates so there's sort of this strange
convergence of fear in the investment
community one is like oh my god with
inflation higher that's going to eat
into corporate profits and with
inflation higher now the fed has to
raise interest rates also eats into
profits and consumers are spending a lot
of money right this second because they
had this excess savings remember that
savings rate jumped up to over 30
percent in april of 2020. the savings
rate is now at 4.4 percent it's the
lowest in 14 years so all these things
converging makes really nervous
investors stocks have sold off the s p
500 the broad u.s index is now coming
towards that bear market territory we're
down almost 19 from the recent high
earlier this year 20 percent's a bear
market it's not a magic number it's just
a marker but it is a very tense time on
wall street so the fed is meeting for
two days next week uh concerns over what
they might do
and specifically whether or not they may
trigger a recession yeah this is a
really hard time for the fed they
definitely started too late in raising
interest rates so inflation has gotten
away from them and that means they're
chasing rates higher they have already
raised interest rates two different
times this year the first by a quarter
of a percent the second time by a half
percent next week they're expected to do
another half percent but be clear when
we were talking about the fed last time
i was on the program we said oh it's
definitely a half percent all of a
sudden there are a lot of whispers maybe
they'll go by .75
maybe they've got to raise rates by more
faster than expected and there is some
concern as you note that the fed itself
can cause a recession by raising rates
too quickly and this is the real problem
for the fed they are trying to thread
that needle and boy it's a hard job but
i'll tell you what next week's going to
be
jerome powell 101. he is going to stand
in front of those cameras he is a tough
guy he's very sure of himself and i
think he's going to say we got this
quickly odds of a recession right now
high um you know unfortunately and so
when i say that i just want to be clear
about one thing recessions are normal
we've had 13 since world war ii we will
have a recession i don't know if it's
this year but it will be within the next
18 months we'll probably have some sort
of softening of growth or a recession
and there you have it jill schlesinger
thanks so much